abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba Ben bilgisayar
mühendisiyim ve ne kadar değerli bir
mesleğim olduğunu anlamam ve anlatmam
uzun yıllarımı aldı
başlarda tanıdıkların bilgisayarına
format atan sihirlerini çalıştıran
evladım bu kumanda niye çalışmıyor
sorularına muhatap olan bir bilgisayarcı
edip Oysa bugün arkeologlarla bloglarla
mimarlarla Birlikte çalışma fırsatı
bulmuş bir bilgisayar mühendisiyim
bugün sizlere
bilgisayarcıdan bilgisayar
mühendisliğini uzanan yolculuğu mu Ve bu
yolculukta domino taşı taşı etkisi
gösteren mentörleri mi anlatacağım
Dilerseniz biraz başa dönelim
ve ailemin tek çocuğuyum
Balkanlar'dan gelmiş bir ve eğitime önem
vermiş veren bir aile e 15 yaşında
Kocaeli'ne yatılı okula
buradaki Fen Lisesi'ne gidiyorum
bu ve orada üniversite dahi tanışmadığım
kadar çok yönlü ve hayatta Derdi olan
insanlarla tanışıyorum ve Tabi o
yıllarda hepimizde biraz da şu var Ben
sadece test çözmekten ibaret değilim
ve edebiyat şiir ve sanata muhteşem bir
merak var hepimizde
Ancak o yıllarda biri ya da bir şey
olmak istediğinizde karşınıza hep şu
cümle çıkıyor Şu sevdiğiniz işi
yaparsanız bir gün bile çalışmış
sayılmazsınız
Bu cümlenin Bizi kara kara düşündüğünü
hatırlıyorum Çünkü o yıllarda her ergen
gibi biz de kendimizi çok ciddi alıyoruz
Meslek seçimini ve üniversite seçimini
hayatımızın en önemli kararı olarak
görüyoruz Tabi o yıllarda
disiplin interdisipliner Lig çok mu
disiplin gibi şeylerden de haberdar
değiliz
ve o Şimdi dönüp bakınca
Keşke Konfüçyüs a değil de küçük prenses
bu kulaklar sevmişiz diyorum video Küçük
Prens gününüzü bu kadar önemli kılan
gününüz için harcadığınız zamandır bir
fırında diyor ki iki ne olmak
istediğinizi değil ne yapmak
istediğinizi düşünün
Oysa biz ne yapmak istediğimizi değil ne
olmak istediğimizi düşünüyor ve mesleğe
Seviyorum Sevmiyorum mutluluk ekseninden
bakıyorduk bir Yine benzer şekilde
tamamen naif bir şekilde sevmek
üzerinden Ben matematiği çok seviyorum
diye düşündüğüm için bilgisayar
mühendisliği eğitimi almaya başladım
var Ancak hissedeki Oo Seviyorum
Sevmiyorum düşünceleri doğru meslekte
miyim oradan oraya savrulma hissi
geçmedi ve Tabi bu yıllarda olacaklardan
habersiz bir şekilde şöyle de bire nişan
var Ne yani ben bütün Hayatım bir ekrana
bakarak mı gelip geliştireceğim Neyse ki
o konuda şimdi hepimiz eşit lendik Çünkü
bu çalkantılar üniversite 4 sınıfta
Boğaziçi bilgisayarda Lale hocamla
tanışınca bitti tilalo Hoca bana dedi ki
bilgisayar grafiği bilgisayarla görme
gibi araştırma konuları var ve İstersen
benimle bitirme tezi yapabilirsin
muhteşem bir başlangıç benim için ve
burada da bilgisayarla görme defterimden
bir sayfa görüyorsunuz
La La La Şa ile tanışınca kadın bir
mühendis
mütevazi bilgili karşımda rol modeli mi
gördüm ve artık o noktadan itibaren ne
olmak istediğimi biliyordum Sen geriye
sadece ne yapmak istediğim kalmıştı Biz
La La hocamda birlikte lisans ve yüksek
lisans birlikte çalıştık ve yüksek
lisansta Bülent hocanın da katkılarıyla
yüz tanıma ve el tanımı üzerinde bir tez
yaptım ve o test sırasında son
kullanıcıya testler yapmaktan çok büyük
keyif aldığımı farkettim
sonrasında İtalya'ya biyomühendislik
okumaya gittim doktora ya
biyomühendislik yapıyor gözükse de
aslında yine görüntü işleme yapmaya
devam ettim ve Serap'ın paslı çocuklar
Normalde işaretleyiciler dediğimiz bu
ekranda gördüğünüz
işaretleyiciler ile birlikte yürümeler
ya oy verildi yapabilmek için ve bunları
çocuklar Işıl Ali ile zannettikleri için
çok zor lan Max Alara bir şeydi ki acaba
bunu hiç zorlamayacak şekilde görüntü
üzerinden Yapabilir miyiz bu benim
doktora tezim dibi ve bu sayede
hastanelerle Tıp doktorlarıyla Serebral
palsi çocuklarla onun anneler ile
çalışma fırsatı buldum ve geliştirdiğim
yazılımın hasta birine Yardım edebilecek
olması düşüncesi beni çok olumlu
etkiledi
sırada ikinci domino taşım var doktor
olacağım uygun
bu ogoo işte doktorun bitirmenin 18 ay
falan kalmış gülerek geldi mi Elif de
değer dedi bizimle devam etmek istersen
tam senlik bir proje var elimde dibi
projede bu
ya Alman kurt köpekleri yürüme analizi
Ne kadar ilginç değil mi değil Çünkü
şöyle bir sorun var Ben 20 yıldır kedi
ve köpek ten acayip korkuyorum ve Hocam
bunu biliyorsun Yok birkaç gün sonra
İstanbul'a gittim arkadaşlarımı dedim ki
böyle böyle hocam bana böyle bir teklif
yaptı bu hepsini tepkisi şu oldu Elif
Bence artık hocam Seninle çalışmak
istemiyorum ama seni koymakta
istemiyorsan anla istiyor yoksa ben
böyle bir proje teklif etmesini başka
bir anlamı olamaz
Oysa döndüğümde görüyorum ki o durum Hiç
de öyle değil o cam köpeği Oliver ve
kedisi maddelerle birlikte benim Korku
mu yani sağladı ve o Bir yılın sonunda
şu minik köpek
kocamın arabasını takip etmiş ve o gün
yani benim köpeğim oldu şimdi bakın
dokuz yıl sonra kedi mi TV Köpeğim
Ailesiyle birlikte mutlu mesut yaşıyoruz
Bu benim için bir domino taşı ydı çünkü
hem çok büyük bir korku mu yendi hem de
Alman kurt köpeklerinin yürümesini
analiz etme bu çok farklı bir üç boyutlu
model geliştirme fırsatı bulduk ve bu
sefer Veterinerler ile çalışma fırsatı
buldum İlk kez
3. dünya taşım ise Profesör bölge zaman
Üniversitesi'nde birlikte ciddi oyun
çalışmaya başladık benim için bir dönüm
noktasıdır Dilerseniz ilk önce ciddi
oyun için bir parantez açayım çünkü
ciddi oyun dediğinizde Nasıl yani oyun
oynarken Ciddi mi duracağım bir bu şey
ifade etmeyen bir tanım Oysa ciltte
sıfatı ciddi eskilerden kaynaklı Yani
bunu yapmayı isteyen enstitüler
defans Eğitim ve Rehabilitasyon gibi
amaçlarla Kısacası sadece eğlence amacı
olmayan oyun demek ciddi oyun
hissediyor ki Transformers şunu Games
yani dönüştüren oyunlar ve ben bu kalıba
vurulur bir profesör bölgenize birlikte
felçli ve ihmal sendromlu Bu hastalar
için oyun geliştirmeye başlıyoruz ihmal
sendromu şöyle bir rahatsızlık değilim
sağ tarafınızdan Felç geçirdiğiniz sol
gözünüzde hiç bir program olmadığı halde
sonraki cisimleri algılamakta
zorlanıyorsunuz Biz bunu aşmak için
haptic bir cihaz yardımıyla video
oyunlarıyla Rehabilitasyon yaptık ve bu
video oyunları bana bambaşka bir dünya
açtık Çünkü artık tek bir kişi olmak
zorunda değilsiniz pek çok kişi olmak
zorundasınız pek çok alanda kendinizi
geliştirmek durumundasınız Çünkü grafik
var insanlara yardım etmek var ses var
senaryo var ve beni hatırlıyorum o
eksiklerimi kapatabilmek için yağlı boya
kurslarına ve çizgi roman çizimi
kurslarına da gitmiştim bu video
oyunları hayatım başka yönden de çok
değiştirdi hatırlarsınız bahsettim
Seviyorum Sevmiyorum mutluluk gibi
kavramlardan hayatta ve Mutluluktan daha
önemli bir şey olduğunu öğretti akışa
çok güzel aslında öyle boş boş
durduğumuz da çok iyi vakit geçiriyoruz
ancak ne zaman ki elimizde topa
sitemizin biraz üzerinde ama yapmaktan
çok da keyif aldığımız bir iş olsun
zamanın nasıl geçtiğini unutuyoruz işte
akış Bu
neden önemli çünkü video oyunları size
bunu sağlıyor Tamam bu video oyunlarının
bunu sağlamasını de önemli şöyle düşünün
Rehabilitasyon dediğiniz şey mesela size
deniyor ki 15 keze oturup kalkacaksın
tekrarlı olarak yapmıştır ve evde kendi
motivasyonunuzu yapması çok zor bir şey
Ne olmuş ki video oyunlarını böyle
şeyleri açmak için kullanalım böyle
farklı bir yola gidelim
benzer şekilde cenmak kaneel Hatta bunu
biraz daha da ileri götürerek diyor ki
bizim diyor gerçekliği tasarladığımız da
bir sorun var eğer diyor bu kadar kişi
bütün gün işlerinde çalıştıktan sonra
hala evlerinde dönüp bilgisayar oyunu
oynayıp oradaki sorunları çözme bilişsel
olarak kendini zorlama problem çözme
yeteneklerini tatmin etmek istiyorlarsa
mi acaba Bizim gerçekliği tasarladığımız
da bir sorun mu var diyor ve ekliyor
eğer biz dünyanın sorunlarını videoyu
olarak düşünebilseydi görebilseydik
acaba sorunları daha bir şey bu
çözebilir dik çokta bu müthiş ilham
verici bir düşünce Ben de otu de iklim
krizi
tasarım ve titrer miras gibi farklı
konularda farklı hocalarla öğrencilerle
çalışma fırsatı buluyorum tedavisini
size bunlardan biraz örnekler göstereyim
biz bu çalışmamızda otu Mimarlık
Fakültesi ile birlikte yaptık burada bir
Mimar bilgisayar başında üç boyutlu
modeli tasarlıyor daha sonra bizim
geliştirdiğimiz sanal gerçeklik ve artık
ama Gerçekte uygulaması ile birlikte
bunu görebiliyor değiştirebiliyor
pencereler ekleyebiliyor kapılar
çıkarabiliyor ve eş zamanlı olarak bu
yaptığı değişikliklerin odanın içindeki
ışığı nasıl değiştirdiğinde görebiliyor
bir sonraki çalışmamızda ise yine otur
Mimarlık Fakültesi ile birlikte Mimarlık
öğrencileri Bir sınıfta temel tasarım
dersi alıyorlar Biz istiyoruz ki acaba
bizi Öncelikle üç boyutlu düşünmeyi bir
uygulama pastasıyla öğretecek burada her
ne kadar arkayı siyah görüyorsunuz dahi
fiziksel ortamın kendisini gördü
göreceğiniz için o şekilde karma gerçek
uygulaması olduğu için hologramlar var
acaba önce orada bir pişse ondan sonra
mı kartonları kes bu sırayı düşünüyoruz
bir çalışmayı Bilkent Üniversitesi İç
Mimarlık Fakültesi ile birlikte de
yaptık ve gerçekten temel tasarım için
sanal gerçekliğin de çok uygun olduğunu
gördük
projemiz ise AB Projesi ile notice bir
al Projesi ve bu projenin içinde farklı
ülkeler birbirlerine gidip
tesbihatlar yapıyorlar bizde otu ekim
olarak dedi ki tatbikat dediğimiz şey
çok fazlasıyla Kural bazı bir şey acaba
Biz her bir işin tek tek oyun
geliştirmek yerine
oyunları geliştirecek Bir yazılım
yetiştirebilir miyiz o yüzden de
otomatik olarak senaryolardan oyunlar
geliştiren Bir yazılım yaptık ki
bu burada Oradaki hastaneye
senaryosundan oyunlar görüyorsunuz
bir sonraki çalışmayı otu maden
Fakültesi ile birlikte yaptık ve
Eskişehir'de yerüstündeki Bir madeni
birebir modellik ve sanal gerçeklik Ama
gerçeklik etkileşimi için testler yaptık
şimdi bunları niye anlatıyorum Bunlar
neden önemli çünkü pandi bize
mesleğimize ve Eğitime yeniden bakma
zorunluluğu getirdi Dyo yüzden biz de
dedik ki acaba bu yaptıklarımızın kaç
kullanılabilir kaçı fiziksel ortam
gerektirir ve pandemi sırasında ot
inşaat mühendisi ile birlikte dedik ki
biz Kaya mekaniği dersini oyun haline
getirelim ve bütün çalışmalarımızı hala
zor üzerinden yaptığımız için henüz
tanışma fırsatı dahi bulamadık ki Ve
kendimi de başka bir vurgu daha çok
yapıldı biliyorsunuz işte Dört Duvar
arasındayız dört duvarın içindeyiz
1965 yılında Emin satırla diyor ki
ileride bu karma gerçeklik hologramlar
vesaire sayesinde tavuğu teknolojileri
belirtmiyor ilerledi öyle günler gelecek
ki diyor o bir odanın içindeki cisimler
gerçekmiş gibi olacak ve biz Alice
Harikalar Diyarında gibi hissedeceğiz
diyor bu cümle benim için çok değerli
oldu çünkü pandemi sırasında Evet dört
duvarın içindeyim ama en azından son
olarak da olsa sevdiklerinle görüşe
Biliyorum sana olarak da olsa işimi
yapıyorum ve Aslında hepimiz Birbirimize
bir an uzağındayız' diye düşünerek Hiç
değilse kendimi bir karma gerçeklik
ortasında hissetmeye Çalıştım o Umarım
bu düşünce Sizlere de iyi bu
silerseniz biraz Panda bulutlarını
dağıtalım biraz komik şeylerden
bahsedelim
videoyu geliştiriyorum dediğiniz anda
çok farklı tepkiler alabiliyorsunuz
Örneğin Üniversitesi'nde bir arkadaşım
Ama videoyu geliştirdiğini söylediğimde
de Nasıl yani sen meslek olarak bir
yolunu geliştiriyor Sun ve üniversitede
üste sana para mı veriyor demişti ama
hala favorim Annem Bayramı gidememiştim
İtalya'da olduğum için akrabalarda
haliyle sormuşlar Elif ne iş yapıyor
diye Ben de o yıllarda kariyerinin
zirvesinde filan olduğunu düşünüyorum
Yaptığım işlerde çok gururluyum Annem
cevap veriyor Aman Elif ne yapsın bütün
bir oyun oynuyor işi gücü oyun bir tek
avantajım var ama çocuklarla aram çok
iyi Hiç öyle Karnen nasıl gibi zor
sorularla gelmiyorum en son hangi oyun
oynadın diyorum ve aramızda arkadaşlık
başlıyor
Evet
şimdi farkettiyseniz hep bir domino taşı
ve domino üzerinden gitmek istedim bir
oyun üzerinden konuşmak ve o mentörleri
o şekilde ifade etmek istedim ve bu
sayede
bildiğim bir oyuna daha yakından bakma
fırsatı buldum ve dedim ki bu ben hemen
Töre domino taşı yapan ne onların farkı
ne ne Çünkü bu üç kişi de içmen törle
bana Bildiklerimi daha yakından bakma
Bildiklerimi altüst etme bana bir ses ve
yeri açma ve beni dönüştürme gücüne
sahiptirler Bence domino taşı olmak bu
demek
bu Orhan Veli'nin Dalgacı Mahmut şiiri
dediği gibi işim gücüm budur benim
gökyüzünü boyarım her sabah hepiniz
uykudayken uyanır bakarsınız ki mavi
Biz mühendislerinde işi gücü Sorunları
çözmek hayatı kolaylaştırmak dünyayı bir
anlığına da olsa daha iyi bir yer haline
getirmek O halde Oyuna devam Çok
teşekkürler